[Music]
if no one minds my schedules a little
tight is it ok if I just take a second
to check in on my Facebook feed right
now yeah all right well let's take a
look here it looks like I have a ton of
notifications going on here let's see
what's going on the New York Jets
invited you to join fumbler that's nice
right there all right good keep going
John Boehner and President Obama invite
you to follow them off the fiscal cliff
thank keep going Chris Brown just
punched you
Guy Fieri invited you to the event rare
photographs of me with my mouth closed
you never see those Nicolas Cage invited
you to send him your screenplay he'll
star in it no questions asked amanda
Bynes invite you to attend her wine
tasting party at 8:30 a.m. Larry King
has invited to the event help Larry King
loosen these damn shards let's see
what's in the newsfeed here there's got
to be something Santa Claus is attending
Hanukkah services at Temple Beth Israel
paranoid Angus T Jones added a new life
event career suicide Jon Cryer likes
cashing my check and minding my own
beeswax Tom Arnold is attending Tom
Arnold goes to Arby's by himself at 120
I
that sounds fun let's see Gary Busey is
now friends with a humidifier Kim
jong-un who likes play on gang Supercuts
very nice
Bill Clinton changes relationship status
to free for the next 56 minutes Israel
and Palestine are now frenemies that's
nice
hey ours a keyboardist Scott Healy has a
new video here yeah coded so it's pretty
good check it out let's check it out
can't wait to see it the can't is Iran
and the pants are off
let's make some magic together I'm
playing in a minor key with a major
erection Healey after dark
that's in this studio yeah yeah you
can't have keys to the studio anymore
yeah alright now let's go back to the
newsfeed check out what's going on Snoop
Dogg has new crops on farmville
Christmas tree and finally Andy Richter
added a new gift right there that's
great
I have fun